hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm cat Alvarado cat Alvarado the
cat have wrought on instance Twitter can
I brought a comedy on Facebook hey cat
we're gonna watch this video that
features Ellen DeGeneres a female
comedian what did you know what cat
Alvarado is also a female comedian who
will be performing in New York City next
week November 5th and 6th at 6 p.m. at
Eastvale comedy club
November 7th at 8:30 p.m. at the
mockingbird November 8th at 8:00 at 2:00
boots Brooklyn and November 9th at 8:00
at comedy cove at Scotty's in
Springfield New Jersey all this is
listen in the description box I've been
to New York before and I've met a few of
you lovely followers out there so I know
some of you guys exist make sure to go
catch her if you have the chance and let
me know the real rejects sets yeah also
uh she performs live shows in LA as well
so if you're in LA try to catch her
following around Facebook so you can get
updated on it apparently Channing Tatum
was guest hosting for Jimmy Kimmel I
love like talk-show host
interviews Ellen DeGeneres let's let's
see this ad this should be fun do if you
danced it would be what was it alright
so how am i doing you should ask me some
questions
stuff like that just show that I could
talk to people which I thought was the
weirdest thing so at my house Alanis
Morissette and Tom Hanks and Helen Hunt
somebody else came over and they
recorded me having a conversation with
them so that they could approve that I
could talk to people I had to like
audition well you're not talking to the
people that we're trying to give me the
job people like to hear you know people
like to talk about themselves so that's
why I don't win friends and influence
people about you I'm being quiet right
now
right because you don't want to know
anything about me now that people are
interested you should be there
go ahead and ruin my dog you seem you're
looking at me I think your first your
first time you were on the show you you
showed me that your spine I think
somebody I really hope that there is no
somebody sent somebody sent it do men
give lap dances or is that not I don't
know what men's personal
[Music]
I do a cherry
[Applause]
that was my note that was the very first
time that my dad actually found out that
I was a stripper for a short time dad
didn't know that you had been a stripper
when he learned it that day even you a
dance yes Wow what's happened with you I
mean your career is so it's it's great I
mean you're a dancer you're doing movies
where you're acting and doing really
serious heavy roles and you're you're an
amazing actor isn't yes so can you
explain this to me I went to go see
Magic Mike and you may wonder why
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
fantastic but there were some people
there that we looked around it looked
like there were some some women who
brought their husbands that Magic Mike
was some kind of magician or they were
so confused of what was going on I think
like actually having a great time does
not have a good time if you're in Vegas
go see Magic Mike glide it's so good it
was so much fun so we did a little tape
piece that we put on my show and we hung
out and and danced we did we played
poker afterwards we played blackjack for
a few minutes
I like I like poker better than
blackjack I do but I do like blackjack
what's uh I don't know I think I read in
your book you have like a crazy story
about a blackjack table well that's
funny we give away stuff all the time
and the one thing we do you know this
cuz you're a guest on the show aren't we
give our guests Ellen underwear because
it's the best underwear
you'll ever
[Applause]
one significant sample ng
[Applause]
[Music]
Ellen underwear underwear and I thought
what can I do to make up for Jimmy's
thriftiness and so
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the Ellen show now
[Music]
the video subscribe if you don't click
subscribe this that was just as funny I
felt like I was doing that a lot more I
really enjoyed the operative him not
doing a good job interviewing oh my gosh
first of all I'm sure there are plenty
of comedians who would have been awesome
guest hosts but no they hadn't get an
actor who's already rich I mean like
comedy is hard okay that's my rant as a
comedian who wants to see doors serious
comedian alright so that's the first
about yes
second of all dude I totally thought
that that was John Cena that's what I've
sent me the most is how much he looks
like John Cena doesn't get interviewed
she doesn't she's always the one doing
the interviewing and of course the one
time she's in the seat that we see her
in that seat the whole thing is about
Shannon and the things that her and
Channing Tatum have done for promoting
Channing Tatum Channing just seems so
nervous the entire time I haven't seen I
mean have you seen one like when Bruce
Willis took over for Letterman for a
week or a day or something well he
doesn't really tell jokes he's better at
the interviewing parts as Bruce Willis
has this natural array of confidence the
Channing Tatum tends to come across like
a little nervous in interviews like a
pretty boy like to say I mean he's
normally scripted and stuff being an
interviewer sounds easier than I have to
do interview gigs before I'm feel like
I'm pretty good at it no yeah you're
good you're good
as I'm pretty good at getting to know
people and asking questions it really is
as simple as Ellen was saying it is it's
just also being funny while interviewing
is the hard part because you don't want
to try to steal the spotlight
Ellen was literally conducting the whole
thing yeah
right when she said people like to talk
about themselves I was like yeah that's
what Channing Tatum's kind of do all you
have to do is really just ask questions
and keep the other person talk yeah
like when she said oh what are you doing
for Thanksgiving and she's like nothing
yeah yeah he was trying to smoothly
transition though he was trying to be
like I think I read about it in your
book and remember you said I'm like did
you actually read the book or he just
say you're so she was making fun of him
for what how he did that so she was good
she was busting his balls I've seen a
lot of celebrities take over and it is
better when a comedian is taking over
like David Spade took over for Jimmy
Kimmel one episode and he did a great
job when it is like the famous people it
can be a little bit more challenging I
think for them they're just not used to
this kind of gig it's a different type
of world
I don't disparage actor they do
something very difficult but this field
is different skills yeah talking I can
see from an outsider perspective being
like well if they're good at that what
they do on camera with acting everything
they should this should be no problem
but it really is a totally different
ballgame
yeah even were like we are actually you
get worse you say the words you want to
think about the words and you just have
to be like what's a fun way I could say
the words that are you have to think
about like how to convey them and you
have to make it a natural conversation
and also it is a it is a form of improv
you have questions as a guide but it is
an improv at the end of the day you have
to make it an entertaining conversation
while you're at it too and that's your
job that guy did but it just so took the
reins gonna make my show they're like we
should just have another host yeah just
in case you know cuz Channing Tatum's
pretty I mean everyone might think he's
John Cena yeah it's a common problem
right here I want to check out more of
what else other segments he's done it
might have been because of the mantle
that it's Ellen I feel like it can
always be a little weird when a host is
interviewing and
their hosts they ass up Conan go on
Colbert and I thought that was gonna be
like brilliant
I love Colbert and I love Conan but it
was kind of awkward yeah ask each other
questions like that how are you doing
how are you enjoyed it a lot more than
you did you what can I say whatever
reaction is right subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell follow Kat online all social media
links in the description box if you're
in the East Coast make sure to catch her
there tell her we sent you check out our
patreon become a patron oject today